foreign
[Music]
music for the other streams uh
presidential live stream
the rules for the game uh for those who
consume alcoholic beverages to make this
more palatable are up at Facebook or I
think they're on the YouTube link uh we
want to thank our sponsors this evening
ar15.com great message board if you need
any tips
or want to talk with people hey arfcom
thanks for watching who um are into
firearms that could be talked about
tonight and of course one of our actual
sponsors we've done some commercials but
prepare with cr.com there is a
promotional uh gift going on right now
99 30 day emergency food kit shipped
free prepare with cr.com 99 bucks set it
and forget it tonight third debate
winner take all I think so I think so
winner take all if you could tweet me at
s Crowder and maybe tweet him at not gay
Jared
um I'd like to make sure that we we have
some ground rules here in the primary
debate we all agree that Fox Business
Chris Wallace did the best job so I know
after debates if someone does well or
doesn't do well they'll blame the
moderator so I want to make sure do we
agree going in that we expect this to
probably be more substantive and Chris
Wallace to do a good job tweet me I'll
see that that'll give me an idea as to
where you line up I think so
I think this debate could be borderline
boring and I think it's a better
environment sometimes for Hillary
um I think Trump won the first debate
I'm sorry I think Hillary won the first
debate I think Trump won the second one
I think by a little bit of a wider
margin if you look at the scientific
polls Hillary won the first debate I
think Trump the first 20 minutes of the
first debate that's the best Trump we've
seen and I think we need to see that a
little more of that tonight what do you
think Jared what does he need to do I
think so I think he needs to come out
hard I think he needs to uh heart or
heart hard hard have you even started
consuming what no not yet I need I
should wait real quick before we get
into it people who are watching along
the live stream uh we have the rules for
the game anytime Trump says frankly you
have them up in your screen anytime
Trump says frankly tremendous trust me
honestly truthfully excuse me let me
tell you China or Mexico or anytime he
interrupts take a drink uh and anytime
he uses the word rigged or he induce
alcohol poisoning if he sniffs drink
water we don't want any deaths in our
hands so drink some water every time he
sniffles uh Hillary anytime she says
Donald coughs laughs inaudibly plays the
sexist card mentions hot sauce yes
what's commits RBF
resting face oh resting face
I forgot about that or the moderator
interrupts on our behalf drink every
time she does a shoulder drink if you
hear the new ones here she tries to make
up a new catchphrase uh kill yourself
yes so what do you think Trump needs to
do we since you started this late you
only have a couple minutes I think he
needs to take they've have you know I
talked to Trump people on Twitter and
they all say no man the wiki the
Wikileaks are enough man the the the uh
James uh O'Keefe stuff was enough their
voter fraud and all those kind of videos
I don't think it's enough because I
don't think either any of those things
are attached enough to Hillary I think
if if Trump come out tonight and marry
those problems to Hillary make her the
symbol of those things it will help him
it won't win no it's not enough but I
think it's something he needs to do
tonight I think Donald Trump needs to
turn this by the way my soundboard isn't
working so I don't know if you don't
have the sound on or what area oh do we
got it yeah that's us there we go there
we go um Trump needs to turn it back on
Hillary Trump needs to turn the her
strategy has been to pull herself out of
the Limelight give him as much of a
stage as possible let the controversies
Mount and sort of back door and I do
think this week has been proof positive
that the media is absolutely in the tank
for Hillary no mention of WikiLeaks
whatsoever no mention of the James
O'Keefe videos I think this is the most
clear example I mean they've always
they've always been in it to win this
for the DNC they just aren't even trying
to hide it anymore with Hillary and
Trump this is nothing new they've just
they're just going all right you know
what yeah this is where we are it's
2016. so I do think that this week has
been proof positive the media
particularly CNN particularly uh anyone
really not named Fox News and some
people on Fox news they want Hillary to
win I think Chris will also do a good
job most of the tweets are saying they
expect him to do a good job let's hear
what he has to say and uh
stay with us between the two
presidential nominees raise your hands
wow okay so you know the undecided
people
what is this
I'm not sure what they're doing it's
happened they're doing that answer is
that them that's them they're doing them
that's the stream yeah uh Justin goodart
says all he has is pumpkin beer and he
hates pumpkin beer that's a horrible
place to be
it's a horrible place to be
um most people some people said the feed
looks a little bit grainy it's gonna be
a long debate with those rules it says
Jesse Levick
um I don't think so I think it's going
to be a good debate by the way keep
Jared accountable not gay Jared
accountable because last time he didn't
drink when he was supposed to drink uh
the rules are we still waiting on a
stream we're still waiting for I'm not
sure what they're doing this stream so
all right I don't think if yeah that was
ABC I don't think they're allowed to
this is is this Fox News Fox Business
it's Fox News right that's cable so it
wouldn't be on the ABC stream not good
Jared let's see what we got here that
would be public I don't think it's
public oh they just went I just found
the fox one they just went up with it
they just went up with a stream at Fox
yep leave it to Fox to get scooped by
another channel on their own stream
their their own stream is usually later
than other people's all right so we have
the stream going yeah but it's just
playing through an ad though so yeah
no Those ads by the way we'll be live
streaming debate night uh not debate
night election night uh with a full
guest list I think we have Shapiro Gavin
Anthony kumia Dean Kane Courtney broad
again Gerald uh the list goes on and on
so election night will be giving you
updates in the electron also Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump will join us
themselves oh wow on Election night
let's use this oh look it's Mr Catfish
Shep Smith you know he came out as gay
really to which the entire world said
wow oh Shep yeah
oh my gosh you did such a good job at
covering it
daytime enemies are paying off all right
just had to crack down on Wall Street
after the 2008 financial he looks like a
catfish he does like you'd expect that
at the end of your line in Lake Michigan
operation we're told yeah it's a river
monster secretary Clinton's first chance
to respond to these new releases the
moderator tonight we're proud to
announce is our own Fox News Sunday
anchor Chris Wallace I think he's a good
job first Fox News journalist to
moderate a general election presidential
debate Shannon bream will watch along
with us and she's live in Washington hi
Shannon hi chef well as viewers of this
fox station know if they've watched them
see the day with that on Fox very
important issues tonight it's very
ambitious agenda now on to our on
locations
foreign policy and also the topic of
who's fits and right for every shot it
used to be Roger doing this
we're live Donald Trump on his business
practices he's a cartoon character and
an anvil would drop on him Outsourcing
so often talking all right so they're
still talking about this stuff so uh
that's what I think is going to happen I
I we'll have a lot to talk about
tomorrow Ben Shapiro kalai Noir Courtney
on tomorrow's live stream
um I wanna you know we'll talk about
tomorrow I noticed a disturbing Trend
with election signs when I was up in
northern Michigan uh some some Trends
there that might surprise some people I
I do think it's important here Donald
Trump needs a knockout win uh and I
listen he's got the media going against
him on this is he Teflon though here's
the truth Hillary's lead is not that
huge
given the amount of controversy that
surrounded Donald Trump and people
coming for it really hasn't stuck I
think they've desensitized a lot of
people to it yes so if he has a good
performance that lead is not
insurmountable here's what I think I
think a Donald Trump win is far more
likely than the media thinks and I think
it's far less likely than his hardcore
supporters think uh you know the betting
odds have it at 85 or 87 13. I'd
probably say It's a 65 35 for Hillary
just in a mathematical possibility
he does
what was that 17 seconds
17 seconds okay here comes Chris Wallace
the only man at Fox News who did not
sleep with Megyn Kelly Center at the
University of Nevada Las Vegas I'm Chris
Wallace
between Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton and Donald J Trump
this debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates the
commission has no the Trump is going
yeah
for the record I decided the topics and
the questions in each topic none of
those questions has been shared with a
commission or the two candidates the
audience here in the hall has promised
to remain silent no cheers booze my
expectations
candidates have to say what no noise
except right now as we welcome the demo
no noise
we have to cycle through this so please
hold your collapse to a minimum no fun
please no fine stop that
thank you
betting pool how long before the shirt
comes off
yours is
that beverage there we go keep him
accountable there we go
secretary Clinton Mr Trump welcome let's
get right to it the first topic is the
Supreme Court
we've you both talk briefly the first
report in the last debate but I want to
drill down on this because the next
president will almost certainly have at
least one appointment and likely or
possibly two or three appointments which
means that you depending on who decides
to kill them
for what could be the next quarter
Century first of all we're breaking news
Clarence Thomas's breaks just went out
in his car secondly what's your view on
how the Constitution should be
interpreted is do the founders words
mean what they say or is it good first
question if this is a substantive debate
this is what Trump needs to show a
contrast between him and Hillary Clinton
you go first that's what he needs for
undecided very much Republicans UNLV for
hosting us you know I think when we talk
about the Supreme Court it's already
drink the central issue in this election
namely what kind of country are we going
to be what kind of opportunities will we
provide for our citizens what kind of
Rights will Americans have
and I feel that the Supreme Court needs
to stand on the side of the American
people not on the side of the powerful
corporations and the wealthy foreign
my opponent about these issues and
others that will be before The Supreme
Court
I feel that at this point in our
country's history uh it is important
that we not reverse marriage equality
that we not reverse Roe v Wade that we
stand up against citizens united we
stand up for the right we stand up
against people who are critical I mean
documentaries and we ensure that we can
still blame terrorism on their YouTube
videos yes that's how I see the court
and the kind of people that I would be
looking to nominate to the court would
be in the great tradition of standing up
to the powerful standing up on behalf of
our rights as Americans and I look
forward to having that opportunity I
would hope that the Senate would do its
job and confirm the nominee that
President Republicans there to them
that's the way the Constitution
fundamentally should operate the
president nominates and then the Senate
advises and consents or not but they
will not forward
or not secretary Clinton thank you I
think not Trump same question what do
you want to see come on Trump or take
the time the Constitution should be
interpreted
well first of all it's great to be with
you and thank you everybody the Supreme
Court it's what it's all about our
country is so so just so imperative that
we have the right just oh he sounds like
it might be something happened recently
where in his throat a little low energy
made some very very inappropriate
statements toward me and toward a
tremendous number of people many many
millions of people that I represent who
did and Hillary she was forced to
apologize and okay
that should never ever have been made we
need a supreme court that in my opinion
is going to uphold the Second Amendment
and all amendments but the Second
Amendment which is under absolute Siege
uh I believe my opponent sniffle we're
supposed to drink water but fear is just
as good I think will happen we will have
a second Amendment which will be a very
very small replica of what it is right
now but I feel that it's absolutely
important that we oppose of the fact
that is under such trauma I feel I think
Donald's mistakes being professional
with bringing the energy down yeah a
little bit and that's just where he's
struggling people want him to be Donald
they just want him to be Donald lasered
in on a point yes they will be
protecting the Second Amendment they are
great scholars in all cases and they're
people of he knows he has to win some
votes here the Second Amendment he knows
that's the biggest winning issue and
it's the biggest issue that could turn
blue dog Democrats away from Hillary yes
hunters and gun owners I believe that's
very very important I don't think we
should have justices appointed that
decide what they want to hear it's all
about the constitution of of and and so
important the Constitution the way it
was meant to be and those are the people
that I will appoint
Mr Trump thank you we now have about 10
minutes for an open discussion I want to
I would like his answer more than
Hillary but he needs to get a little
more focused on him yes back by the
Justice bring up the energy Focus end up
changing the existing law of the land
first is one that you mentioned Mr Trump
and that is gone secretary Clinton you
said last year let me quote the Supreme
Court is wrong on the Second Amendment
and now in fact in the 2008 Heller case
the Court ruled that there is a
constitutional right to bear arms but a
a right that is reasonably limited those
were the words of the of the judge
antonyms exceptionally supports the
Australia buyback which is a mandatory
gun she supports Second Amendment
every time she lies drink drink that
deserves several chunks Upstate New York
I understand and respect the tradition
of gun ownership it goes another life of
our country but I also believe
reasonable regulations reasonable it's a
live drink because I support the Second
Amendment doesn't mean that
foreigns that would make a difference
that are not in any way conflicting with
the Second Amendment you mentioned the
Heller Decision and what I was saying uh
that you referenced Chris was that I
disagreed with the way the court I'm
trying to kill Jared
little mess because I'm not part of your
body count
was to protect toddlers from guns and so
they wanted people with guns to safely
stop toddlers imagine like right now you
know right now
conflict between mean saving people's
lives and defending the Second Amendment
let me bring Mr Trump in here the
bipartisan open debate Coalition got
billions of votes on questions to ask
here and this was in fact one of the top
questions that they got how will you
ensure the Second Amendment is protected
you just heard secretary Clinton's
answer does she persuade you that while
you may disagree on regulation that in
fact she supports a Second Amendment
right to bear arms well the DC versus
Heller Decision was very strongly and
she was extremely angry about it I
watched
Justice Scalia was so involved and it
was a well-crafted decision but Hillary
was extremely upset extremely angry and
people that believe in the Second
Amendment and believe in it very
strongly were very RBF what she had to
say
were you extremely upset well I was
upset because as unfortunately dozens of
toddlers
injure themselves even kill people with
guns because unfortunately not everyone
by the way
um
future hillarys that is not in conflict
with sensible commentations
I understand that Donald's been strongly
supported by the NRA the gun Lobby's on
his side they're running millions of
dollars of ads against me and I regret
that because what I would like to see is
for people what two to one three to one
four to one we're going to need to keep
up with the beers tonight Amendment but
we're going to do it in a way that tries
to save some of these 33 000 lives that
we lose every year most of whom are
toddlers And propeller caps in fact you
oppose any limits on assault weapons any
limits on high-capacity magazines you
support and here's your Christmas is
using the gun control terminology and
doesn't realize it let me just tell you
before we go any further in Chicago
which has the toughest gun laws oh let
me tell you drinks Donald Trump probably
you could say by far they have more gun
violence than any other city so we have
the toughest laws and you have
tremendous gun violence I am a very
strong supporter of the Second Amendment
and I am I don't know if Hillary was
saying it in a sarcastic manner but I'm
very proud to have the endorsement of
the NRA and it's the earliest
endorsement they've ever given to
anybody who ran for president
we are going to appoint justices this is
the best way to help the Second
Amendment we are going to appoint
justices that will feel very strongly
about the second amendment that will not
do damage to the Second Amendment well
let's pick up on another issue which
divides you and the justices that
whoever ends up winning this election
the points could have a dramatic effect
that there and that's the issue of
abortion right Mr Trump you're from life
but I want to ask you specifically do
you want the court including the
justices that you will name to overturn
Roe v Wade which includes in fact States
that's a loaded question and I will be
appointing pro-life judges I would think
that that will go back to the individual
states but I'm asking you specifically
would you like they overturned it it'll
go back to the States but what I'm
asking you sir is do you want to see the
court overturned you just said you want
to see the Court protect the Second
Amendment do you want to see the court
overturn well if we put another two or
perhaps three justices on that's really
what's going to be that's will happen
and that'll happen automatically in my
opinion because I am putting pro-life
injustices on the court I will say this
it will go back to the states and the
states will then make a determine that
seems a little bit like it has a job
strongly support I'll give you that one
which guarantees a constitutional right
to a woman oh all of a sudden the
broad's about constitutional rights
to sticking forceps up your who ha and
dragging a baby out for the dumpster
fire for Thursday
are putting very stringent regulations
on women that block them from exercising
by the way people listening the
stringent laws from these states like
abortions all kinds of cancers no longer
legal after 22 weeks have you seen a 22
week old baby Donald has said these
aren't crazy right-wing laws like you
see in places like Texas just be clear
this when she says crazy laws people are
thinking they're going to toss you in
jail for having an abortion no it's one
of fetus when a baby is essentially
viable where it could be taken out of
the womb almost
we don't want abortions
which is supported even by abortionists
by the way turn back now now and in
indeed he said women should be punished
that there should be some form of
punishment uh for women um
and I could just not be more opposed to
that kind of thinking I'm going to give
you a chance to respond but I want to
ask you secretary Clinton I want to
explore how far you believe the right to
abortion goes you have been quoted as
saying thread the fetus has no
constitutional rights you also voted
against a ban on late term partial birth
abortions why
because Roe v Wade very clearly toddlers
can I get abortions that there can be
regulations on abortion
into account they're giving them penises
and when I voted why not a senator I did
not think that that was
kinds of cases that fall at the end of
pregnancy are often the most
heartbreaking painful decisions for the
baby who's dismembered with women who
toward the end of their pregnancy get
the worst news one could get that their
health is in Jeopardy if they continue
to carry to terms or that something
terrible has happened or just been
discovered about the pregnancy I do not
thinking
for women who killed their baby at 24
weeks most personal of decisions
moment for a woman who's jamming
scissors up her baby's head at 24 weeks
am I missing something
just prior to the birth of the baby now
you can say that that's okay and Hillary
can say that that's okay but it's not
okay with me because
[Music]
good answer from Trump good answer that
is not what happens in these cases and
using that kind of uh scare rhetoric
because it's just terribly unfortunate I
appreciate that you should meet with
some of the women that I've met with
women I've known over the course of my
life this is one of the worst possible
choices that any woman in her family has
to make and I do not believe the
government should be making it you know
I've had the great honor of traveling
across the world on behalf of our
country I've been to countries where
governments either forced women
to Bear children like they used to do in
Romania and I can tell you the
government has no business in the
decisions that women make with their
families in accordance with their faith
with medical advice and I will stand up
what if we just left all right but just
briefly I want to move on toddlers
perform abortions with guns doing what I
just said doing that we're out as late
as one or two or three or four days
prior to birth nobody has that all right
let's move on to the subject of
immigration There is almost no issue
that separates the two of you more than
the issue of immigration actually there
are a lot of issues that separate the
two of you Mr Trump you want to build a
wall secretary Clinton you have offered
no specific plan for how you want to
secure our Southern border Mr Trump you
are calling for nature deportations his
plan is unrealistic
you're going to offer a package that
includes a pathway to citizenship uh the
question really is why are you right and
your opponent wrong Mr Trump you go
first in this segment you have two
minutes well first of all she wants to
give amnesty which is a disaster and
very unfair to all of the people that
wait for many many years we need strong
borders in the audience tonight we have
four mothers of I mean these are this is
his best performance Festival that I've
gotten to know over a period still
within 20 minutes they've been killed
brutally killed by people that came into
the country illegally you have thousands
of mothers and fathers and relatives all
over the country they're coming in
illegally drugs are pouring in through
the Border we have no country if we have
no border Hillary wants to give amnesty
she wants to have open borders the
border secure as you know the border
patrol agent 16 500 plus ice last week
endorsed me first time they've ever
endorsed a candidate it means their job
is tougher but they know what's going on
did they know it better than anybody
they want strong borders they feel we
have to have strong borders I was up in
New Hampshire the biggest complaint they
have but he needs to give the plan
problems going on in the world a lot of
people even Republicans they don't feel
like they have a good purchase plans yes
yes
it's poison the blood of their youth and
plenty of other people
we have to have strong borders we have
to keep the drugs out of our country we
are right now we're getting a bunch of
Libertarians
I want to build the wall we need the
wall the border patrol that was great
nice
will be to get all of the drug lords all
of the bad ones we have something I know
one more time I missed the grab on that
one in this country
we'll make a determination as to the
rest but we have some bad ombres here
and we're going to get them out oh God
that's gonna be a sound bite same
question
you're right oh well I love talking I
was thinking about a young girl I met
here in Las Vegas Carla uh who was very
worried that her parents might be
deported because she was born in this
country but they were not they work hard
they do everything they can to give her
a good life and you're right I don't
want them
I don't want to be sending parents away
from children I don't want of course
deportation force that Donald has talked
about
wanting open borders we have 11 million
undocumented people they have four
million American citizen children 15
million people he said as recently as a
few weeks ago in Phoenix that every
undocumented person would be subject to
deportation now here's what that means
it means you will have to have a massive
law enforcement presence where law
enforcement office
school to school home to home business
to business rounding up people who are
undocumented and we would then have to
put them on trains on buses to get them
out of our country you know you could
put them on those those railroad pumps
well the same buses used to funnel in
voters
I voted for border security in the
United States Senate and my
comprehensive immigration reform plan of
course includes border security but I
want to put our resources she has so
much makeup on tonight you wouldn't know
she had lips
anybody who should be deported we should
Deport it would just be like when you
blur a face on YouTube in a hidden
camera video we went to Mexico we had a
meeting with the Mexican president
didn't even raise it he choked and then
got into a Twitter war because the
Mexican president said we're not paying
for that wall so I think we are both a
nation of immigrants and we are a nation
of laws and that we can act accordingly
and that's why I'm introducing
comprehensive immigration reform within
the first hundred days with a path to
citizenship thank you secretary Clinton
I want to follow up I think it's I think
I should respond to that first of all I
had a very good meeting with the
president in Mexico very nice band we
will be doing very much better with
Mexico on trade deals he said no the
NASA deal signed by her husband
any kind signed by anybody it's a
disaster Hillary Clinton wanted the wall
Hillary Clinton fought for the wall in
2006 or thereabouts
but Hillary Clinton wanted the wall well
look at that smile from her look at that
that's his Ledger Joker yeah
just do it for border security and there
are uh so there are some limited places
where that was appropriate there also is
necessarily going to be new technology
and how best to deploy that uh but it is
clear when you look at what's look at
his face posing he started this is the
danger zone immigrants
we started six minutes late and drug
dealers if he gets pissed enough she's
going to toss out what we should do to
deal it's a matter of does he bite on it
what I am also arguing is that bringing
undocumented immigrants out from the
Shadows putting them into the formal
economy will be good because then
employers can't exploit them and
undercut America
he basically said what a lot of
employers do you complain I'll get you
deported I want to get everybody out of
the Shadows get the economy working and
not let employers exploit undocumented
workers which hurts them but also hurts
American workers no it doesn't President
Obama has moved millions of people out
nobody knows about it nobody talks about
it but under Obama millions of people
have been moved out of this country
they've been deported she doesn't want
to say that but that's what's happened
and that's what's happened big league as
far as moving these people out and
moving we either have a country or we
don't we're a country of laws we either
have a border or we don't now you can
come back in and you can become a
citizen but it's very unfair we have
millions of people that did it the right
way they're online they're waiting we're
going to speed up the process Big League
because it's very inefficient but
they're online and they're waiting to
become citizers very unfair that
somebody runs across the border becomes
a citizen under her plan you have open
borders you would have a disaster on
trade and you will have a disaster with
your open borders we will say is that
president has deported millions and
millions of people just the way
secretary Clinton
[Music]
this used to be a bipartisan issue
Ronald Reagan
immigration reform and George W bush
supported it as well secretary Clinton I
want to yes the problem is
the speaker gave to a Brazilian bank for
which you were paid 225 000 we've
learned from the Wikileaks that you said
my dream is a hemispheric common market
with open trade and open border soap
thank you
I was talking about uh energy you know
we trade more energy with our neighbors
than we trade with the rest of the world
combined and I do want us to have a an
electric grid and energy
process borders I think that would be a
great benefit to us but you are uh very
clearly uh quoting from Wikileaks and
what's really important about Wikileaks
Russians the Russian government has
engaged in Espionage against Americans
they have hacked American she's looking
down websites American accounts of
private people of Institutions then they
have given that information this is
forcing her to spar a little bit which I
like for the purpose of putting it on
the internet this has come from the
highest levels of the Russia
she probably can't pronounce the Russian
names
17 of our intelligence agencies have
confirmed to influence our election so I
actually think the most important
question and all your other donors
influence the election huh finally will
Donald Trump
this is
keep it quiet so for the candidates and
for the American people
she he wants open borders people are
going to pour into our country people
are going to come in from Syria she
wants 550 percent more people than
Barack Obama and he has thousands and
thousands of people that have no idea
where they come from and you see we are
going to stop radical Islamic terrorism
in this country
[Music]
if we got along well that would be good
if Russia and the United States got a
long way Mr Isis
he has no respect for her he has no
respect for our president and I'll tell
you what we're in verse because we have
a country
tremendous numbers no nuclear warheads
1800 by the way where they expanded and
we didn't 1800 nuclear warheads and
she's playing chicken look
from everything I see has no respect for
this person well that's because he'd
rather have a puppet
no problem it's pretty clear it's pretty
clear you won't admit the Russians have
engaged against the United States of
America that you encourage come on
Donald just say it Espionage against our
people that you are willing to spout the
Putin line sign up for his wish list
break up NATO do whatever he wants to do
and that you continue to get help from
him because he has a very clear daughter
in this race so she's looking to think
that this is such an unprecedented uh
situation we've never had a foreign
government trying to interfere sure
intelligence agencies
exactly what you just said all concluded
I feel like I'm watching Happy Days
Espionage
the highest levels of the Kremlin and
they are designed to influence our
elections
she has no idea whether it's Russia
China or anybody
you have no idea 17 Intel do you doubt
17.
billion agencies well yeah he'd rather
believe it Vladimir Putin than the
military and civilian intelligence
professionals who are sworn to protect
us I find that just absolutely because
Putin has outsmarted her at every step
of the way excuse me
in Syria
you'll get to ask some questions yes and
she has lipstick on her teeth with the
blood of small children National
Security officials of this country do
believe that Russia has been behind
these hacks
even if you don't know for sure whether
they are do you condemn any interference
by Russia in the American election by
Russia or anybody else you condemn their
interference of course I condemn of
course I can I don't know Putin I have
no idea
this is not my best friend but if the
United States got along with Russia
wouldn't be so bad let me tell you Putin
has outsmarted her and Obama at every
single time of the way whether it's
Syria no you name it people are mad
because we were crazy
yeah it's because we know what Hillary
is you only discipline a child you care
about we wanted to see Trump improved he
allowed us to do this they create
warheads and we can't the Russians can't
believe it she has been outsmarted by
Putin and all you have to do is look at
the Middle East they've taken over we've
spent six trillion dollars they've taken
over the Middle East she has been
outsmarted and outplayed worse than
anybody I've ever seen in any government
whatsoever
immigration but I'm going to let you
finish this you've got about 45 seconds
yeah and she always will be I I find it
uh ironic that he's raising nuclear uh
weapons this is a person who has a very
Cavalier and Casual about the use of
nuclear weapons he's advocated more
countries getting them Japan Korea even
Saudi Arabia he said well if we have
them why don't we use them which I think
is uh terrifying but here's the deal the
bottom line on nuclear weapons is that
when the president
followed there's about four minutes
between the order being the makeup chair
at CNN is just responsible for launching
nuclear weapons to do so that's why
who have had that awesome responsibility
have come out in an unprecedented way
said they would not trust Donald Trump
with the nuclear codes or to have his
finger on the nuclear button I have 200
21 Congressional Medal of Honor
recipients as far as Japan and other
countries we are being ripped off by
everybody under we're defending other
countries we are spending a fortune
doing it they have the bargain of the
century all I said is we have so many
negotiations our country cannot afford
to defend Saudi Arabia Japan Germany
South Korea and many other places we
cannot continue she took that a second
look she's been proven
ways this is just another lie let them
think I'm just quoting you uh when
there's no quote you're not going to
find a quote from me clear
Trump interrupting competition in Asia
you said you know go ahead enjoy
yourselves folks that kind and defend
yourself well and defend yourself I
didn't say nuclear and defend yourself
United States has captured peace even
though you are alliances Donald wants to
tear up our alliances I think it makes
the world safer and frankly it makes the
United States wait I would work with our
allies do we drink in Europe
that's the only way we're going to no
we're gonna we are going to move on to
the next topic
which is the economy and I hope we
handle that as well as we did
immigration uh
you also have very different ideas about
how to get the economy growing faster
secretary Clinton in your plan
government plays a big role you our
company
let me tell you Maximus
thank you diesel penalties uh Mr Trump
you want to get government out with
lower taxes
a little bit more but in this overview
please explain to me why you believe
that your plan will create more jobs and
growth for this country and your
opponent's plan will not in this round
you go for a secretary Clinton well I
think when the middle class thrives
America thrives and so my plan is based
on growing the economy giving middle
class families many more opportunities I
want us to have the biggest jobs program
since World War II jobs and
infrastructure and advanced
manufacturing I think we can compete
with high-wage countries and I believe
we should new jobs and clean energy not
only to fight climate change change
which is a serious problem but to create
new opportunities new businesses I want
us to do more to help small business
that's where two-thirds of the new jobs
I want us to raise the national minimum
wage because people who live in poverty
should not who work full-time should not
still be in poverty and I sure do want
to make sure women get equals
you will not get a tuition bill from a
public college or university if the plan
with Bernie Sanders is enacted and we're
going to work hard to make sure that it
is we are going to go where the money is
most of the gains in the last years
since the Great Recession have gone to
the very top so we are going to have the
wealthy pay their fair share we're going
to have corporations uh make a
contribution greater than they are now
to our well they pay half that is a plan
that has been answered independent
experts which said that it could produce
10 million new jobs by contrast Donald's
plan has been uh analyzed
three and a half million jobs why
because his whole plan is to cut taxes
to give the biggest tax breaks ever
she's really wealthy and to corporations
adding 20 trillion dollars to our debt
and causing the kind think of this for
this location that we have nobody wants
to open borders and to weaken the
standing of American businesses with
higher corporate taxes do you have an
idea how devastating that would be to an
American economy
protectionism I'm not anti-free trade
like Trump
fairly I think but I'm the opposite of
where he is on trade but Hillary wants
open borders the American economy
taxes for tax plan is a disaster and she
can say oh she wants another College
tuition and I'm a big proponent we're
going to do a lot of things for college
tuition but the rest of the Public's
going to be paying for it we will have a
massive massive tax increase under
Hillary Clinton's plan but I'd like to
start off where we left because when I
said Japan and Germany and I'm not to
single them out but South Korea there's
a very rich powerful countries Saudi
Arabia nothing but money we protect
Saudi Arabia why aren't they paying she
immediately when she heard this I
questioned it and I questioned NATO why
aren't the NATO questioned why aren't
they paying because they weren't paying
since I did this this was a year ago all
of a sudden they're paying and I've been
given a lot of a lot of credit for it
all of a sudden they're starting to pay
up they have to pay up we're protecting
people they have to pay up and I'm a big
fan of NATO but they have to pay up she
comes you're not a big fan of NATO we
love them we think our allies are great
well it's awfully hard to get them to
pay up when you have somebody saying we
think how great they are we have to tell
Japan in a very nice way we have to tell
Germany all of these countries South
Korea we have to say you have to help us
out we have
Obama's regime we've done it needs to
get into this place a little more we're
up to 20 trillion do you think this is
enough of a performance so my plan we're
going to renegotiate trade this we're
gonna have a lot of free trade we're
going to have free trade more friends
being taken out by the deal that her
husband signed NAFTA one of the worst
deals ever yeah
this doesn't really you look at all help
him so much in Pennsylvania
if there's anything to be gained by this
being in home throughout Arizona
oh that's right that's right you can't
make a great deals in Nevada and we're
going to terminate NAFTA and we're going
to create new deals we're going to have
trade but we're going to turn we're
going to terminate it we're going to
make a great trade deal and if we can't
we're going to do it we're going to go a
separate way because
I don't want to do away with napkins
you can't say that you're against
raising a minimum wage but your four
tariffs are taxes on things if we
eliminate NAFTA and he proposes Trade
Agreement that's fair I'm on board well
let me I'm not on board with punishing
businesses like Ford to go to Mexico
he's going to so uh he Advocates he's
getting with me Cuts we've ever seen
three times more than uh the tax cuts
under the Bush Administration I have
said repeatedly throughout this campaign
I will not raise taxes on anyone making
250 000 or less I also will not add a
penny to the debt I have costed out what
I'm going to do he will through his
massive tax cuts add 20 trillion dollars
for the debt we mentioned the debt we
know how to get control of the debt when
my husband was President we went from a
300 billion dollar deficit to a 200
billion dollar Surplus and we're
actually a little bit that you don't
want to drink
when President Obama came into office he
inherited the worse since the Great
Depression
by two-thirds good Hillary yeah
go after the debt one of the ways
and the opportunities for people to get
ahead and stay ahead that's the kind of
approach that will spit your beer
cutting taxes on the wealthy we've tried
that so it has not worked the way
secretary Clinton I want to pursue your
plan because in many ways it is a
stimulus plan in 2009 uh which has led
to the slowest GDP growth since 1949.
correct
thank you sir you told me in July when
we spoke that the problem is that
President Obama didn't get to do enough
in what he was trying to do with this
stimulus so is your plan basically more
even more of the Obama stimulus
venation Chris and let me say that
when you inherit the level right now
bill is in the audience going economic
catastrophe that President Obama
inherited uh it was a real Touch and Go
situation I was in the Senate before I
became Secretary of State I've never
seen uh people as physically distraught
as the Bush Administration uh team was
because of what was happening to the
economy I personally believe really
under Bush for many years
saved the economy he doesn't get the
credit he deserves for taking some very
hard positions but it was a terrible
recession so now we've dug ourselves out
of it we're standing but we're not yet
running so what I am thinking she just
dug herself out of the recession
the ground up not the top down that is
not going to work no one wants to see
your top-down dealership
[Music]
will enable more people to take
we're beginning to see some increase in
incomes and we certainly have had a long
string of increasing jobs we've got to
do more to get the whole economy moving
and that's what I believe I will be able
to do Mr Trump even conservative
economists who have looked at your plans
say that the numbers growth
is unrealistic by the way tonight
sponsored and they say you talk a lot
about it
they don't sponsors they're helping us
get through this so I just left some
high representatives of India they're
growing at eight percent uh China is
growing it and that for them is a
catastrophically low number oh this one
we are growing our last word came out
and it's right around the one percent
level
freezer last week as you know the end of
last I'm gonna grab it by that they came
out with an anemic jobs report a
terrible job in fact I said is that the
last jobs report before the election
because of it is I should win easily it
was so bad the report was so bad
pouring in from China pouring in from
Vietnam pouring in from all over the
world I've visited so many communities
this has been such an incredible
education Chris I've gotten to know so
many I've developed so many friends over
the last year
and they cry when they see what's
happened I pass factories that were
thriving 20 25 years ago and because of
the bill that her husband signed and she
blessed 100 percent
it is just horrible these people in
these communities now she can say that
her husband did well why did they suffer
as NAFTA kicked in because it didn't
really kick in very much
after they left boy did they suffer that
was one of the biggest things that's
ever inspired now she wants to sign
trans-pacific partnership and she wants
it she lied when she said
yes she did call it the gold state
actually okay and they said I was right
I want to give you a chance to briefly
speak to that that I want to Pivot to
100.
Obamacare yeah go ahead well briefly
first let me let me say number one uh
when I saw the uh
who was helping with the live tweets
right now my tests I've had the same
test meaning Aaron does it put jobs
raise incomes and further our national
security I'm against it now I'll be
against it after the election I'll be
against it when I'm president there's
only one of us on this stage who's
actually shipped jobs to Mexico because
that's Donald he's a chip job that's
because you've never employed anybody
and you know one of the biggest problems
we have with China is the illegal
dumping of Steel into our markets I have
fought against that as a senator I've
stood up against it as Secretary of
State Donald has bought Chinese steel
and aluminum in fact the Trump Hotel
right here in Las Vegas was made with
Chinese steel so he goes around with
crocodile tears about how terrible it is
but he has given jobs to Chinese Steel
Workers not American Steelers that's the
kind of approach yourself is just not
going to work we're going to pull the
country together
that's why I'm going to have they'll go
she's got a prosecutor for the first
time in history and we're going to
enforce those agreements and we're going
to look for businesses to help us by
buying American Products I asked a
simple question she's been doing this
for 30 years why the hell didn't you do
it over the last 15 20 years you were
very much involved excuse me my turn
excuse me you were very much involved in
every aspect of this country very much
and you do have experience this is a
strong one thing you have a point but
it's bad experience what you've done has
turned out badly for 30 years you've
been in a position to help and if you
say that I use steel or I use something
else I make it impossible for me to do
that I wouldn't mind the problem is you
talk because you don't get anything done
Hillary you don't just like when you ran
the state department
six billion dollars was missing how do
you miss six billion dollars you ran the
state department six billion dollars was
either stolen they don't know it's gone
six billion dollars
well first of all what he just said
about believing department is not only
untrue it's been debunked numerous times
I think it's really an important issue
he raised the 30 years of experience
they just talk briefly about that you
know could you imagine this back in the
1970s defense
uh discrimination against
African-American kids in schools I am
now he was getting sued yesterday
discrimination she's going personal more
than he is that's a first I do notice
policy
economy she's going to he didn't rent
the black kids that said he makes it
really easy you can't for him yeah it's
true you can't say let's go back to the
issues don't even tweeting about Miss
Universal night that he makes it but
this is the first time she's done it yes
and on the day a when I was in The
Situation Room
monitoring The Raid that brought Osama
Bin Laden to Justice he was hosting the
Celebrity Apprentice so I'm happy to
compare my 30 years of experience what
I've done for this country
every way I could especially kids and
families get ahead and stay ahead with
your 30 years and I'll let the American
people make that decision well I think I
did a much better job I built a massive
company a great company some of the
greatest assets and anywhere in the
world uh worth many many billions of
dollars I started with a one million
dollar loan I agree with that it's a one
million dollar loan but I built a
phenomenal company and if we could run
our country the way I've run myself you
just have a stroke we would have he said
it looks like Stephen Hawking he said I
would even be proud
take a look at Iraq she gave us Isis
because
and a small group came out of that huge
vacuum because
once we were there we should have never
got out the way they wanted to get out
she gave us Isis
and what happened is now Isis is in 32
countries and now I listen how she's
going to get rid of Isis she's going to
get rid of nobody all right we are going
to get to foreign
you said your talk about grabbing
nothing women prick was just that talk
and that you'd never actually done it
and since then as we all know nine women
have come forward and said that yeah but
one of them in the New York Times looks
like Jill kissed them without their
consent
why would so many different women from
so many different circumstances over so
many different years why would they all
in this last couple of weeks
make up you denied us why would they all
make up these stories and since this is
a question for both of you secretary
Clinton
Mr Trump says what your husband did and
that you defended was even worse Mr
Trump you go first of all those stories
have been largely debunked those people
I don't know those people I have a
feeling how they came I believe it was
her campaign that did it just like if
you look at what came out today on the
clips where I was wondering what
happened with my rally in Chicago and
other rallies where we had such violence
she's the one in Obama that caused the
violence they hired people they paid
them fifteen hundred dollars and they're
on tape saying be violent no cause
fights they're not Democrats are I would
say that I only wait because those
stories are all he's right in spirit the
fact Checkers are going to sidestepping
and say false Hillary and Obama sitting
right here yeah because I didn't
remember the DNC did that's a little bit
I didn't see these women these women the
woman on the plane the woman I think
they want either fame or her campaign
did it and I think it's her campaign
because when I saw what they did for him
no which is a criminal act by the way
where they're telling people to go out
and start fist fights and start violence
and I'll tell you what grabbing by the
prison killer in Chicago
and people could have been killed in
that Riot and that was now all on tape
started by her I believe Chris they're
gonna say she got there's no more
10 minutes of fame but they were all
totally it was all fiction it was lies
and it was fiction
those things where you should set up in
a way that makes people think I could be
but without ever actually saying it this
was a little the overreaching overages a
little bit too much
and after that a number of women have
come forward uh saying that's exactly
what he did to them now what was his
response please explain to me why you
believe those numbers
oh okay not possibly have done uh those
things to those women because they were
not attractive enough for I didn't
necessarily assault I did not say that
in fact he went on to say or to hurt sir
her two minutes but did not say that for
two minutes he went on to say look at
her I don't think so about another woman
he said that wouldn't be my first choice
he attacked the woman reporter writing
the story called her disgusting as he is
called a number of women during this
campaign
thinks belittling women makes him bigger
he goes after their dignity their
self-worth and I don't think there is a
woman anywhere who doesn't know what
that feels like
so we now know oh you what Donald what
he says and how he acts toward women
that's who Donald is
I think it's really up to all of us to
demonstrate oh by the way Texas cards
and who our country is and to stand up
and be very clear about it's hard for to
get through this you know she's
stumbling she's replacing the next bill
with Donald how we want to bring our
country together it's difficult where we
don't want
to have the kind of pitting of people
who won against the other times
make our country even greater
America is great because America is good
and it really is up to all of us to make
that true now and in the future and
particularly for our children and our
grandchildren Mr Trump nobody has more
respect for women
there's nobody has more respects
everybody and frankly frankly drinking
those sewers have been largely debunked
and I really want to just talk about
something slightly different
she mentions this which is all fiction
All fictionalized probably or possibly
started by her and her very sleazy
campaign but I will tell you
where she destroyed 33 000 emails
criminally criminally after getting a
subpoena from the United States Congress
what happened to the FBI I don't know we
have a great General four-star general
today you read it in all the papers
going to potentially served five years
symbolically to every life lost violence
to the people to Congress symbolism
he's going to probably go to jail this
is a Four Star General and she gets away
with it and she can run for the
presidency of the United States he's
right it's really what you should be
talking about not with this audience
where somebody wants fame or where they
come out of her crooked campaign
secretary Clinton well
every time uh Donald is pushed on
something which is obviously
uncomfortable like what these women are
saying
um he immediately goes to denying
responsibility uh and it's not just
about women
he never apologizes or says he's sorry
for anything so we know what he has said
what he's done to women he used to say
that but now but he also went after a
disabled reporter mocked and mimicked
him on Nationals oh I don't remember he
went after Mr and Mrs Khan the parents
of a
young man who died serving our country a
gold star family because of their
religion
people who aren't captured
he went after the dick move a federal
judge born in Indiana
but who Donald said couldn't be trusted
to try the fraud and racketeering case
against Trump University because his
parents were Mexican so it's not one
thing this is a pattern a pattern of
divisiveness of a very dark and in many
ways dangerous vision of our country I
love my lawyers
punching at his rallies that is not who
America is and I hope that as we move in
the last weeks of this campaign more and
more people will understand what's at
stake in this election it really does
come down what kind of countries you
know so sad when she talks about
violence at my rallies and she caused
the violence it's on tape during the
last the other day things are false but
honestly I'd love to talk about honestly
training or devices and I'd love to talk
about other things okay but those other
charges as you know in this bucket about
Fitness to be president there's been a
lot of developments over the last
everyone's screenshots
I'd like to ask you about about them
these are questions that the American
people we have secretary Clinton tweet
it during your 2009 Senate confirmation
hearing you promise to avoid even the
appearance of a conflict of interest in
the conservative with your dealing with
the Clinton Foundation while you were
Secretary of State but email show the
donors got special access to you those
seeking Grace
martial arts you know considered
separately from non-donors and some of
those donors got
contract government contracts taxpayer
money
can you really say that you kept your
pledge to that senate committee and why
isn't what happened
why isn't it what Mr Trump called
Everything I did as secretary of state
was in furtherance of uh our country's
interests and our values the state
department has said that I think that's
been proven but I am happy in fact I am
thrilled to talk about the Clinton
Foundation because it is a world
renowned charity and I am so proud of
the work that it does you know I could
talk for the rest of the debate I know I
don't have the time to do that but just
briefly uh the Clinton foundation made
it possible for 11 million people around
the world
needs to afford treatment and that's
about half of all the people in the
world who are getting treatment in
partnership with the American Health
Association we have made environments in
schools healthier secretary
respectfully this is a this is an open
discussion well it isn't
Saudi Arabia giving 25 million dollars
Qatar all of these countries you talk
about women and women's rights so these
are people that push gaze off business
off buildings these are people that it's
true
give back the money that you've taken
from certain countries that treat
certain groups of people so horribly why
don't you give back the money I think it
would be a great gesture well I guess it
takes this amount of money and you take
a look at that I was in Little Haiti the
other day in Florida it's like a little
China
the clintons because what's happened in
Haiti with the Clinton Foundation is a
disgrace I would just love you Hillary
to be honest and everybody knows
one for you Trump 90 of all the money
that is donated on behalf of programs
to use that's not my fault I'm very
proud of that we have the highest rating
from The Watch dogs that follow
foundations and I'd be happy to compare
what we do
which took money came other people and
bought a six-foot portrait of Donald I
mean who does that it just was
astonishing but when it comes to Haiti
Haiti is the poorest country in our
hemisphere the earthquake and the
Hurricanes it has devastated Haiti uh
bill and I have been involved in trying
to help Haiti for many years the Clinton
Foundation 30 million dollars
catastrophic uh earthquake and she
doesn't suspect any terrible problems
the people there had we've done things
to help small businesses Agriculture and
so much else and we're going to keep
working to help Haiti because it's an
important part of the Americans they
don't want you to help them anymore
I'd like to mention one thing Trump
Foundation small Foundation people
contribute I contribute the money goes
100 100 goes to different charities
including a lot of military I don't get
anything I don't buy boats I don't buy
planes what happens
wasn't some of the money used to settle
your lawsuit sir no it was we put up the
American flag and that's it they put up
the American flag we fought for the
right in Palm Beach to put up the
America there was a penalty that was
imposed by Palm Beach County
by the way the money I went to Fisher
house where they build houses the money
that you're talking about went to Fisher
house where they built houses for
veterans and disabled I want to get into
one of course there's no way we could
say
candidate ever to run for president in
the last 40 plus years who has not
released his tax returns so everything
he says about charity or anything else
we can't prove it you can look at our
tax returns we've got them all out there
but we're really troubling not impressed
is that we learned in the last debate he
has not paid a penny in federal income
tax and we were talking about immigrants
a few minutes ago Chris you know half of
all immigrants undocumented immigrants
in our country actually pay federal
income tax so we have undocumented
immigrants in America who are paying
more federal income tax than a
billionaire I find that so let me just
tell you astonishing we're entitled
because of the laws that people like her
pass to take massive amounts of
depreciation on other charges that we do
it and all of her donors just about all
of them I know Buffett took hundreds of
millions of dollars Soros George Soros
took hundreds of millions of dollars let
me just explain
most of her do is
because your donors and your special
interests are doing the same thing as I
do except even more so well you should
have changed a lot but you won't change
the law because you've taken so much
money I mean I sat in my apartment today
on a very beautiful hotel down the
street known as paid with Chinese deal
but I will tell you I sat there I sat
there watching add after add after at
false ad all paid for by your friends on
Wall Street that gave so much money
because they know you're going to
protect them and frankly uh you should
have changed if you don't like what I
did you should have changed the law Mr
Trump I want to ask you about one last
question in the in this topic here's the
problem these two only rallies racing 11
months ago we're hanging out at cocktail
parties together yeah don't make
anything I'm enjoying this show I don't
trust any of them trying to steal it
from you
you're on the stage tonight do you make
the same commitment to you well
absolutely sir that you will absolutely
accept the result of this election I
will look at it at the time I'm not
looking at anything now I'll look at it
at the time what I've seen what I've
seen is so bad first of all the media is
so dishonest and so corrupt and the
pylon is so amazing that the New York
Times actually wrote an article about it
that they don't even care it's so
dishonest and they've poisoned the minds
of the voters
Donald Trump was citing the New York
Times against Ted Cruz
you look excuse me Chris if you look at
your voter rolls you will see millions
of people that are registered to vote
Millions this isn't coming from me this
is
that shouldn't be registered to vote
well so but that's you but a lot of them
let me just give you one other things
for example if you move from Michigan
somewhere else for like a Daily Show
she's she's no longer supposed to
actually register to vote there that's
included in the numbers so you need to
know the real number just in that
respect I say it it's rigged because she
should never trust she should never have
been allowed to run for the presidency
based on what she did with emails and so
many other things
in this country and stick with peaceful
transition of power and that no matter
how hard Florida campaign is that at the
end of The Campaign that the loser
concedes to the winner not saying that
you're necessarily going to be the loser
or the winner but that the loser
concedes to the winner and that the
country comes together in part for the
good of the country are you saying
you're not prepared now is that I will
tell you at the time I'll keep you in
suspense well Chris let me respond to
that because that's horrifying you know
every time Donald thinks things are not
going in his Direction he claims
whatever it is slipping said Alpha the
FBI conducted a year-long investigation
into my emails They concluded there was
no case he said the FBI was rigged he
lost the Iowa caucus he lost the
Wisconsin Primary he said the Republican
primary was rigged against him then
Trump University gets sued for fraud and
racketeering he claims the court system
and the federal judge is rigged against
him there was even a time when he didn't
get an Emmy for his TV program three
years in a row and he started tweeting
that the Emmys were rigged should have
gotten it oh by the way this is a
mindset
Donald thinks and it's funny but it's
also really troubling okay now that is
not the way our democracy Works we've
been around for 240 years we've had free
and fair elections we've accepted the
outcomes when we may not have liked them
and that is what must be expected of
anyone standing on a debate during a
general election you know President
Obama said the other day when you're
whining before hold on hold on folks it
just shows you you're not up to doing
the job and let's you know let's be
clear about what he is saying and what
that means he is denigrating he's
talking down our democracy and I for one
am appalled that somebody who is the
nominee of one of our two major parties
would take that kind of position I think
what the FBI did and what the Department
of Justice did into his management with
her husband the attorney general in the
back of an airplane on the tarmac in
Arizona I think it's disgraceful I think
it's a disgrace I think we've never had
a situation hold on folks this doesn't
do any good for anyone let's please
continue the debate and let's move on to
the subject of foreign hot spots the
Iraqi offensive to take back mosul has
begun
if they are successful in pushing prices
out of that City and out of all of Iraq
the question then becomes
what happens the day after and that's
something that whichever of you ends up
president is going to have to confront
will you put do you need anyone U.S
troops into that vacuum to make sure
that Isis doesn't come back or isn't
replaced by something even worse
secretary Clinton you go first in this
segment you have two minutes
well I am encouraged that uh there is an
effort led by the Iraq humans I'm
guaranteed to hate my life supported by
Kurdish forces and back uh no also given
the help and advice from the number of
Special Forces and other Americans on
the ground but I will not support
putting American soldiers into Iraq as
an occupying Force I don't think that is
in our interests and I don't think that
would be smart to do in fact I think
that would be a big I'll leave them
there to Die waving for Isis to
reconcosystem the goal here is to take
back mosul it's going to be a hard fight
I've got no Gary Johnson somewhere Moses
into Syria
take back and move on raqqa which is the
Isis headquarters
I am hopeful that the hard work that
American Military advisors have done
will pay off and that we will see uh a
real a really successful military
operation but we know we've got lots of
work to do Syria will remain a hotbed of
terrorism as long as the Civil War aided
and abetted by the Iranians and the
Russians continue so I have said look we
need to keep our happy crisis that's why
I want to have an intelligent surge that
protects us here at home why we have to
go after them from the air on the ground
online why we have to make sure here at
home we don't let terrorists buy weapons
if you're too dangerous to fly you're
too dangerous to buy a gun and I'm going
to continue to was that quite a phrase
fly zone and safe havens within Syria
not only to help protect the syrians and
prevent the constant outflow of refugees
but to frankly gain some leverage Donald
Trump the series
the kind of serious negotiation
necessary to bring the conflict to an
end if he says it explains it why this
is a strong same question if we are able
to push Isis out of mosul and out of
Iraq will would you be willing to put
U.S troops in there to prevent
their return or something else let me
tell you also so sad we had mosul
but when she left when she took
everybody out we lost muscle now we're
fighting again to get most
probably with muscle and what they
wanted they wanted to get the leaders of
Isis who they felt were in mosul about
three months right now it's going to it
he won a campaign
I wouldn't trust Gary whatever happened
Family Feud okay much less we announced
now for about how long is it at least
three months
these people have all left
they've all left the element of surprise
Douglas MacArthur George Patton spinning
in their graves when they see the
stupidity of our country so we're now
fighting from us someone just tweeted
out I'm with her Steven Crowder now
we're going into clearly haven't been
watching but you know if at any point
is because she's running this isn't the
stream The Office of president if they
want to look tough they want to look
good he violated the Red Line in the
Sand we missed it let me tell you he
made so many mistakes made all mistakes
that's why we have the Great Migration
but she wanted to look good for the
election so they're going in but who's
going to get muscle really we'll take
muscle eventually by the way if you look
at what's happening much tougher than
they thought much much tougher much more
dangerous going to be more deaths than
they thought but the leaders that we
wanted together
what do we need this for I go crazy
is going to be a wonderful thing and
Iran should write us a letter of thank
you just like the really stupid the
stupidest of all time a deal that's
going to give Iran absolutely nuclear
weapons Iran should write us yet another
letter
saying thank you very much because Iran
as I said many years ago Iran is taking
over Iraq something they've wanted to do
forever but we've made it so easy for
them so we're now going to take muscle
and you know who's going to be the
beneficiary Iran boy are they making I
mean they are outsmarting
I look you're not there you might be
involved in that decision but you were
there when you took everybody out of
mosul and out of Iraq you shouldn't have
been in Iraq but you did vote for it you
shouldn't have been in Iraq but once you
were in Iraq you should have never left
the way the point is your two minutes is
going to be Iran
well you know once again uh Donald is
implying that he's talking about how you
thought that was a bad deal anyways I
said it was a mistake I said that years
ago he has consistently denied what is a
very clear fact that before The Invasion
he supported it and you know I just want
everybody to go Google it Google Donald
Trump Iraq and you will see the dozens
of sources which verify that he was for
the invasion of Iraq and you can
actually hear the audio
well it matters because he has not told
the truth about that position I guess he
believes it makes him look better now to
contrast with me because I did vote for
it but what's really important here is
to understand all the interplay mosul is
a drink Worthy is on the border of Syria
and yes we do need to go after baghdadi
and uh just like we went after uh
uh while you were doing Celebrity
Apprentice and we brought him to Justice
we need to go after him
get rid of them get rid of their
Fighters they're estimated several
things
they've been digging underground they've
been prepared to defend it's going to be
tough fighting but I think we can
apparently missed like ten dollars
and take back raqqa this is what we have
to do I'm I'm just amazed that he seems
to think that the Iraqi government and
our allies and everybody else launched
the attack on mosul to help me in this
election but that's how Donald thinks
you know he always looking for something
Chris we don't gain anything he has all
that Iran is taking over Iraq secretary
Clinton Iran is taking over Iraq
secretary please
secretary Clinton it's an open
discussion secretary
please like Mr Trump's face he's unfit
and he proves it every time you are the
one that's in fit you know Wikileaks
just actually came out John podestus
said horrible things about you news.com
he said some Beauties and you know
Bernie Sanders
and if you think that going into mosul
after we let the world know we're going
in and all of the people that we really
wanted the leaders they're all gone if
you think that was good then you do now
John podesta said you have terrible
instincts Bernie Sanders said you have
bad judgment I agree with both well you
should ask Bernie Sanders who he's
supporting for president and he has said
which is a big mistake
of America I think he's a sexy nurse
outfit in the dungeon
Mr Trump in the last debate you were my
slave masters must pay there the
situation in the Syrian City
you said several things in that debate
that's racist
has basically fallen in fact there are
okay
have you seen it have you seen it
and they are being slaughtered because
of bad decisions if I may just finish
here and you know also said that I said
that Syria and Russia are busy
fighting Isis in fact they have been the
ones who've been bombing and shelling
Eastern Aleppo uh and they just
announced a humanitarian pause in effect
admitting that they have been bombing
and shelling Aleppo would you like to
clear that up well uh Aleppo is a
disaster it's a humanitarian nightmare
but it has fallen from the state from
any standpoint I mean what do you need a
signed document take a look at Aleppo it
is so sad when you see what's happening
I know this one because what's happening
I know this one hitting his head with a
Vans off the wall
it's like it's like we're watching
reruns of Jeopardy you're like I know
this question I know it's not a person
it's much tougher and much smarter than
her and Obama and everyone thought he
was gone two years ago three years ago
he lined he aligned with Russia he now
also aligned with Iran who we made very
powerful he gave them 150 billion
dollars back we give them one point
I mean cash bundles of cash as big as I
didn't mention that we gave them one
point now
they have lined he has aligned with
Russia
and with Iran they don't want Isis but
they have other things because honest
Jesus said we missed a disaster we're
back in Rebels we don't know who the
rebels are we're giving them lots of
money lots of everything we don't know
who everything
and it's not going to happen because you
have Russia and you have Iran now but if
they ever did overthrow Assad you might
end up with as bad as Assad is and he's
a bad guy but you may very well end up
with worse than a son
if she did nothing
would be in much better shape and this
is what's caused the Great Migration
where she's taking in tens of thousands
of Syrian refugees who probably in many
cases not probably who are definitely in
many cases Isis aligned and we now have
them in our country and wait do you see
where there's going to be the great
Trojan Horse and where do you see Bill
Clinton what happened
thanks a lot for doing a great job
secretary Clinton you have talked about
and in the last debate and again today
that you would impose a no-fly zone I
would say I was doing better at the
beginning the people of Aleppo and to
Stop The Killing he's not doing badly
but this isn't enough to convince that
because he fears it's good the people
who aren't already
yeah it's also not toxic settings
staff says you and opposed a no-fly zone
my chances are you're going to get it
into a war his words with Syria and
Russia so the question I have is a
no-fly zone first of all how do you
respond to their concerns secondly if
you impose a no-fly Russian plane
violates that does President Clinton
shoot that line down well Chris first of
all
I think a no-fly zone could save lives
and could hasten the end of the conflict
I am well aware of the really legitimate
concerns that you have expressed from
both the president and the general uh
this would not be done just on the first
day this would take a lot of negotiation
it would also take making it clear to
the Russians and the syrians that our
purpose here was to provide safe zones
on the ground we've had millions of
people leave Syria and those millions of
people uh inside Syria who've been
dislocated so I think we could
be very clear
um syrians that this was something that
we believed was in the best interests of
the people on the ground in Syria it
would help us with our fight against
Isis but I want to respond to what
Donald said about you notice they're
saying Isis now
I've always thought Obama was the only
one really sticking with that it's like
he was left and that was the one thing
that really bothered me about fiorina
she started using isil for a while
while he's
haunting and so we are going to do very
careful vetting that does not solve our
internal challenges with Isis and our
need to stop radicalization to work with
American Muslim communities
to identify and prevent attacks in fact
my wife beerwents didn't like that one
sorry Dad dozens of people at the
nightclub in Orlando the Pulse Nightclub
was born in Queens the same place Donald
was born so let's be clear about what
the threat is and how we are best going
to be able to meet it and yes some of
that threat emanates from over in Syria
and Iraq and we've got to keep fighting
and I will defeat Isis and some of it is
we have to up our game
I want to get into our final segment
it's so ridiculous what she will defeat
it you should have never let Isis happen
in the first place
wait one second the
Russia took over vast swatches of land
and then they said we don't want the
ceasefire anymore we are so outplayed on
missiles on ceasefires they are
outplayed now she wasn't there I assumed
she had nothing to do with it but our
country is so outplayed by Putin and
Assad and by the way and by Iran nobody
can believe how stupid our leadership is
Mr Trump secretary some of them we need
to move on to our final segment and that
is the national debt which has not been
discussed until tonight
our national debt as a share of the
economy our GDP is now 77 that's the
highest since just after World War II
but the nonpartisan committee for a
responsible federal budget says
secretary Clinton under your plan debt
would rise to 86 percent of GDP over the
next 10 years Mr Trump under your plan
they say it would rise to a hundred and
five percent of GDP over the next 10
years to me this is a pointless segment
I watched the debates with um McCain and
Obama I say they're wrong because they
both talked about how they were reduce
all the debt from really how far is this
is what it is now and if she got in
it'll be less than zero but we're
bringing it from one percent up to four
percent and I actually think we can go
higher than four percent I think you can
go to five or six percent and if we do
you don't have to bother asking your
question because we have a tremendous
machine we will have created a trend
tremendous tremendous Dynamic machine
once again to do that we're taking back
jobs we're not going to let our
companies be rated by other countries
where we lose all our jobs we don't make
our product anymore it's very sad it's
not true but I'm going to create a
there's more money that we were from the
standpoint of Industry we used to be
there we've given it up we've become
very very sloppy we've had people that
are political hacks making the biggest
deals in the world bigger than companies
you take these big companies these trade
deals are far bigger than these
companies and yet we don't use our great
leaders many of whom back me and many of
whom back Hillary I must say but we
don't notice those people those are the
people secretary Clinton to Hillary
because she kept saying Donald tonight
it's only Hillary Hillary was he saying
secretary said secretary good because I
want you to be very happy remember I do
remember that get the position because
they gave they made a campaign
contribution you know they're dealing
with China
very much smaller exactly than they are
or do so we have to use our great people
but that being said we will create an
economic machine the likes of which we
haven't seen in many decades and people
Chris will again go back to work and
they'll make a lot of money and we'll
have companies that will grow and expand
and start from the debate secretary
Clinton well first when I when I hear
Donald talk like that and know that his
slogan is make America great again I
wonder when he thought Americans by the
way was great our audiences
rushes and says you know before you and
President Obama were there I think it's
important to recognize that he has been
criticizing
um our government for decades you know
back in 1987 he took out a 100
000 ad in the New York Times during the
time when President Reagan was President
and basically said exactly what he just
said now that we were for the laughing
stock of the world he was criticizing
President Reagan this is the way Donald
thinks about himself with himself
the middle and says you know they're
just trying to score points it as he
said on the convention I don't see what
the point is but if you look at it is
for her
yes I pay for everything I'm proposing I
do not add a penny to the national debt
I take that very seriously because I do
think it's one of the issues we've got
to come to grips with so when I talk
about how we're going to pay for
Education how we're going to invest in
infrastructure how we're going to get
the cost of prescription drugs down and
a lot of the other issues that people
talk to me about the time I've made it
very clear we are going where the money
are going to ask the wealthy and
corporations to pay their fair share and
there is again
that that will slow down or diminish our
growth in fact I think just the opposite
will have what economists call middle
outgrowth we've got to get back to
rebuilding the middle class the families
of America that's where growth will come
that's why I want to invest in you I
want to invest in your family and I
think that's the smartest way to grow
the economy today
and we just have a big disagreement
about this it may be because of our
experiences you know we started off with
his dad as a millionaire I started off
with my dad as a small businessman we've
heard this before I think it's you know
it's a difference the personal affects
how we see the world and what we want to
do with the economy time thank you
Hillary could I just respond well no
well no because we're running agree with
Ronald Reagan very strongly on trade I
disagreed with him we should have been
much tougher in trade even then I've
been waiting for you actually okay
desert right similar to Trump the
Harley-Davidson AMF days he protected
Harley
is entitlements which is 60 percent of
all federal spending now the committee
for federal responsible federal budget
has looked at both of your plans and
they need the reviews
serious
Medicare is going to run out of money in
the 2020s Social Security is going to
run out of money in the 2030s and at
that time recipients are going to take
huge cuts in their benefits so in effect
the final question I want to ask you in
this regard as soon as he said let me
start with you Mr Trump that's what's
trending would president Trump make a
deal with Medicare and Social Security
tax increases and benefits
it's going to grow at a record rate but
that's not going to help it's going to
totally help you and one thing we have
to do repeal and replace the disaster
known as Obamacare it's destroying our
country it's destroying our businesses
our small business and our big
businesses we have to repeal and and
replace Obamacare you take a look at the
kind of numbers that that will cost us
in the year 17 it is a disaster if we
don't repeal and replace now it's
probably going to die of its own weight
what Obamacare has to go it's the
premiums are going up 60 70 80 percent
next year they're going to go up over a
hundred percent and I'm really glad that
the premiums have started at least the
people see what's happening because she
wants to keep Obamacare and she wants to
make it even worse and it can't get any
worse bad Health Care this is important
most expensive repeal but Hillary is
pandering to people who don't pay for
Health Care Donald Trump is pandering a
working America Social Security that's
important to know any working American
who pays for Health Care knows that what
he just said is true anyone who expects
us you and I the taxpayer to pay for it
a deal wants to support Hillary Clinton
that's a pivotal difference to try to
save both programs well Chris I am on
record as saying that we need to put
more money into Social Security trust
fund that's part because
there's nothing face taxes on the
wealthy my Social Security payroll
contribution will go up as will Donald's
assuming he can't figure out how to get
out of it uh but what we want to do is
to replenish this trust fund by making
sure that we have sufficient resources
and that will come from either raising
the cap and or finding other ways to get
more money into it I will not cuter look
so funny I want to if I mean
and for women who have been
disadvantaged by the current social
security system
but what Donald is proposing massive tax
cuts will result in a 20 trillion dollar
additional national debt that will have
dire consequences for Social Security
and Medicare and I'll say something
about the Affordable Care Act which he
wants to work Affordable Care Act
extended the solvency of the Medicare
trust fund so if he repeals it our
Medicare problem gets worse what we need
to do is gosh that means Medicare is not
enclosed I mean Medicare that means that
Medicare has been rated and now they're
trying to fill that hole they're trying
to plan for doing it to plug that hole
that sinking ship to get entitlement
with money from subsidized Obamacare
which by the way there's more resource
is focus on filling holes the final time
probably to both of your Delight that
you're going to be on the stage together
in this campaign
I would like to end it on a positive
note you had not agreed to uh closing
statements but it seems to me in a funny
way that might make it more interesting
because you haven't prepared closing
statements so I'd like you each to take
it we're going to put a clock up a
minute
as the final question in the final
debate to tell the American people why
they should elect you to be the next
president this is another new Mini
segment secretary Clinton it's your turn
to go first well I would like to say to
everyone watching tonight that I'm
reaching out to all Americans Democrats
Republicans and independents because we
need answer on everybody make our
country what it should be at least
in real time now
skills your commitment your energy your
ambition you know I've been privileged
to see the presidency up close and I
know the awesome responsibility of
protecting our country and the
incredible opportunity of working to try
to make life better for all of you I
have made the cause of Children and
Families really my life's work that's
what my mission will be in the
presidency I will stand up for families
against powerful interests again
that your kids have good educations from
preschool through college I hope you
will give me a chance
secretary Clinton thank you Mr Trump
she's raising the money from the people
she wants to control doesn't work that
way but when I started this campaign I
started it very strongly it's called
make America great again we're going to
make America great we have a depleted
military it has to be helped has to be
fixed we have the greatest people on
Earth in our military we don't take care
of our veterans we take care of illegal
immigrants people that come into the
country illegally better than we take
care of our vets that can't happen our
policemen and women are disrespected we
need laws we need Justice
walking to the store they have no
education they have no jobs I will do
more for African Americans and Latinos
than she can ever do in 10 lifetimes all
she's done is talk to the
African-Americans and to the Latinos but
they get the vote and then they come
back they say we'll see you in four
years we are going to make America
strong again and we are going to make
America great again and it has to start
now we cannot take four more years of
Barack Obama and that's what you get
when you get her
thank you both
secretary Clinton hold on just a moment
folks secretary Clinton Mr Trump I want
to thank you both for participating in
all three of these debates that brings
to an end this year's debate sponsored
by the commission on presidential
debates we want to thank the University
of Nevada Las Vegas and its students for
having us now the decision is up to you
while Millions have already voted
Election Day November 8th is just 20
days away one thing everyone here can
agree on we hope you will go vote it is
one of the honors and obligations of
living in this great country
thank you and good night
thank you very much okay for people you
should tune in for the uh debate wrap up
here
so this is someone insulted they said
they said not gay Jareds
you know you're small yes so once I'm
not gay gear it's my peers
his wife feeder is just hanging off his
shoulders it looks like it goes straight
into his pants and someone said on
ar15.com
said uh not Gage Aaron's dandruff
shampoo is just called Head
I hope people can appreciate it that's
fair we both appreciate good insults yes
we really do well as you show that you
tried we constantly get insulted by our
biggest fans we just called that's funny
that's good writing a party wants to
hire him as a writer
um
all right I'm looking on Twitter what do
we take away from this debate except
that not Gage Yard can't even take a
session four percent uh shinerbach I
think Trump someone said this well Trump
won the first 30 minutes
Hillary probably pulled ahead in that
second 30 minutes and the last 30 was
about a draw
so this is interesting because the first
debate Trump won the first 20 and then
definitely got massacred after that the
second debate Trump won by a hair but it
didn't seem to help him enough this one
I would say I would say Donald Trump won
but not by a huge margin
so the question becomes this
there are fewer and fewer undecided
voters as we get to election day right
now that number is less likely to change
as more people have made up their minds
not good here what do you do you think
this performance from Trump here's the
main question the main question is this
Hillary is ahead by over seven in the
RCP if you want to go into the polls
being rigged I don't think polls are
rigged I really don't I think some of
them can be wrong for example not gay
Jared wasn't sure he might have answered
a poll as undecided and now he's voting
for Trump so I think they can be wrong I
don't think they're rigged but if you
look at the polls they have followed
uh the events of okay uh scandal with
Donald Trump women come forward okay he
plummets Hillary Clinton Wikileaks okay
she so so it's been pretty consistent so
I don't think that there's as much of a
secret Trump voter as people think I
think they've accounted for that
especially in the wake of brexit
the question becomes Jared Hillary in
the RCP average
assuming there isn't some crazy outlier
where Trump's actually had 15 as these
conspiracy theorists believe let's say
he's behind
was this enough of a performance for
Donald Trump to change the course of the
election within the last two weeks
in short no no I think it'll give them a
few points Advantage I think he will um
I think I think this is probably his
best performance thus far I'd say so I
say it's his best friends for the first
20 minutes in the first debate followed
by this overall followed by this overall
I think he was at least consistent
pretty much throughout this whole debate
he had a couple weaker moments but I
think he was probably his best so far I
don't think it's enough to change a
whole lot I think he'll give him an edge
he certainly didn't lose any ground
tonight which
I think I think the Wikileaks all that
stuff I think it's been has been great
it's been fun it's not enough to change
the course election I think if unless
there's a bombshell like a bombshell
That Rocks the media something that
means tape of her and Huma yes something
the media cannot turn it I a blind eye
to for three to four days just consumes
the media and like I said 20 days is
that what it is the election
I think he needs something like that to
really have a chance my mom asked do you
think Donald is on Xanax and my dad said
Trump is winning that's the magic of low
expectations I think there's some truth
there Trump hasn't performed super well
in the debates and here's the deal
when you have all these other sites that
say Trump dominated every debate well
guess what it rings Hollow when in this
debate
in the last debate we said he won by a
thin margin I would say this is probably
similar to debate number two
a handful more of strong moments tonight
than he did debate number two I said
5149 Trump yeah I would say debate
number three I might like 60 40 60 40
yeah the first debate I'd probably put
80 20 Hillary
so it's is it is the cumulative effect
enough here now here's the deal when you
read other sites it said the first
debate first debate was Landslide Trump
win because you read a bunch of online
non-scientific posts well guess what
just remember that they lied to you
whereas now we're being truthful so you
know when we say we think Donald Trump
actually won this I think he won I think
he did better I think Hillary Clinton
noticeably the biggest difference from
the other debates
she was the one to go personal first and
it's not just what she did you keep
returning to that too often the personal
stuff and I think that's who she knows
where that's where she has to gain some
ground because that's all her fan her
photo base has been I think that's the
biggest Grudge I don't see any sjw on on
Twitter or anybody taking real grievance
with Trump's policies granted he hasn't
made them super cool because he made
them super clear but that's not it's all
personal he's a racist he's this he's
he's a sexist he's a misogynist he's a
xenophobic I think that's where she's
trying to take tonight and I don't think
it worked as well as I think she was
hoping for words I think that that tells
a story that's more important not only
does she go personal but that tells a
story of an absence of trump initiating
personal attacks yeah so that means it
put her on the offensive in a way that
she hasn't been because Donald Trump got
personal so he seemed like a bully makes
it easy for them to say he's a sexist so
Hillary got personal first which uh has
allowed Donald Trump I think tonight to
talk a little bit more about policy I
think the thing we said when we came out
here he needs to turn the attention on
Hillary she did some of that herself but
he needs to give people a firm grip a
firm purchase more so on a specific
policies
I think number one happened I don't
think number two happened enough to
change the course of the current
election however
it was enough of a win that if there is
some kind of a bombshell or if he is
able to get out in front of the media
he could gain some ground now of course
right now one of the top trends is bad
Hombres which shows you the media is
going to focus on that that they're not
going to focus on the Clinton Foundation
they're not going to focus on Wikileaks
they're not going to focus on Saudi
Arabia they're not going to focus on the
illegal donations they're not going to
focus on the emails they're going to
focus on Donald Trump saying bad Hombres
here's the deal Donald Trump I think gra
talking about having an affair with a
married woman that's bad I don't think
saying there are some bad ombres is even
remotely offensive I don't think it's
even remotely racist I have no problem
with it so when you hear me say that
you know I'm being
consistent I am zero Parts offended and
I don't think most Americans are
offended so I'll be interested to see
what happens with this I think if the
media catches on to the bad hombres
I think that could be an example here so
watch this in the following days I do
think that could be an example of
overreach if they go can you believe he
said that bad Hombres I think a lot of
Americans particularly undecided are
gonna go well yeah that's I've watched
The Good the Bad and the other that's
not racist at all and it still depends
yeah it depends and I think they're
going to try to whipping out the Mexican
thing out the Mexican thing but I think
that Hombres is actually even less it is
it is which is we should make it even
more telling right so I do think this is
actually a good thing the fact that
they're jumping on bad ombres I think
Solon huffpo slate they're going to try
and make that a racist Gaff I think most
people know that that is inherently
untrue and I think most people will
reject it so we may be looking at gift
horse in the mouth
the media May overreach Donald Trump
didn't win it by a huge margin but
they're latching onto something not
Machado Miss Universe they're latching
onto something not grab them by the p
word they're latching onto something
which is entirely defensible and most
Americans would say come on that's not
offensive and they'll reject the
politically correct culture so this
actually could play into Donald Trump's
hands the bad hombre I would that's an
instance where I would say Donald be you
fight back on that don't apologize don't
move back an inch you need to apologize
for the Billy Bush tape you need to do a
part you need to to back off the Machado
thing bad ombre
go nuclear scorched Earth you're fine
that would be my advice to him what do
you think
I think so I think uh it's very telling
watching the media respond to this it's
the last their their last chance seeing
these candidates up front in front of
the camera Hillary we know she hides
so I wish that if there was a bombshell
coming I kind of wish it would have
fallen before tonight I wish it would
because it's I think because she hides I
think it's gonna be less obvious to the
public I think it's going to be become
less front and center I think of what it
should have fallen before tonight but
what do I know
um I think the media how they respond to
those things will be very telling my
point is Trump could use that with this
night the debate I don't think the
election was changed enough barring some
unforeseen incident I think Trump
probably loses but I'm actually seeing
the bad Hombres Trend right now
um that could be a real opportunity they
don't know it yet I think if they so
make sure you guys can fight back on
that
um I think if they overreach it might
make it really easy to catch them with
their pants down so I don't think this
was enough of a performance from him but
I think they're so
in an echo chamber where they they
genuinely think right now that everyone
is going to read Donald Trump said bad
Hombres that's like the n-word I'm
switching my vote I think that changes
Republican zero I think it probably
changes Democrat zero because at this
point if you're voting Democrat you're a
social justice warrior in the tank for
them and I think that actually would
turn some Independence toward Donald
Trump even Gary Johnson between tokes
and Aleppo he'll say well bad hombre is
pretty absurd that's benign like my
tumor from all this pot pot heads right
now are saying uh pot cures cancer so
again prepare with cr.com our sponsor 99
uh 30-day emergency food supplied kit
good stuff it's good stuff great price
shipped free tomorrow on the live stream
we are going to have Ben Shapiro kalayan
Noir from the NRA Courtney scoffs and uh
top five movies classic movies classic
films you couldn't do today could not
make today and we'll be following up and
reading some of your tweets regarding
the live uh the debate live stream of
course remember election night will be
here Donald Trump Hillary Clinton and an
All-Star cast Gavin McGinnis Ben Shapiro
Dean Kang Courtney brought again so many
people so many surprise guests think of
it like the Dean Martin Show only people
won't be drunk Christmas is coming early
except for maybe even not gay Jared
auction what a crazy election season
thanks for being with us louder with
Crowder every Thursday live at 8pm
Eastern we'll see you there unless
you're racist you bad ombres
[Music]